while the nation focuses on scandal
other serious problems are actually
cropping up the latest updates in the
Trump investigations hand we will check
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
every day another piece of news and
every piece of news more annoying than
the last so much to get to today we'll
get to all of it first let's talk about
your second Amendment right so if you're
a law-abiding citizen you want to press
your family you want to protect your
country you want to protect your home
well then you should probably have a gun
and you should also know how to use that
gun and that's where the u.s. CCA comes
in right now you have a chance to win
big from the US ECA because the u.s. ECA
wants to give you a free gun right now
they're giving away a different gun
every single day this month but they are
going fast you're almost out of time to
win go to defend your family now calm to
get entered right now you could get up
to 17 chances to win your gun every day
it could be 17 kimber 17 Glocks maybe
even that new Sig Sauer they're running
out fast get yours right now all you
have to do is go to defend your family
now calm to reveal the gun you could
take home today it's totally free
remember not a lot of time the gun of
the day always disappears at midnight
they're almost gone so hurry it's your
big chance to take home one of these
guns
don't miss out go to defend your family
now dot-com to get entered to win that
free gun right now that's to fend your
family now.com again defend your family
now calm the occa also provides you all
sorts of educational and legal resources
that you need and want as a law-abiding
gun owner you should be a member in any
case go check them out it defend your
family now.com defend your family now
calm okay so let's begin with all of the
legal updates in the investigation into
president Trump and the Trump
Organization and in campaign finance
violations and and all the rest of it
there's a good piece today from Kimberly
Strauss all about the feeling that a lot
of folks on the right are getting that
this is all one-sided and President
Trump is among those who feel that this
is all one-sided that the investigations
into Trump have been consistent non-stop
and were never mirrored by any similar
investigations into the Hillary Clinton
Foundation or into hit the into Hillary
Clinton's emails this feeling that there
are a lot of folks who were responsible
for bad action on the left side of the
aisle but got away with it because there
was no specific special investigation
that was dedicated to them and there's
some truth to this Kimberly strassens
column today is all about this she
points out in the country has watched
the FBI treat one presidential campaign
with kid gloves the other with
informants warrants and eavesdropping
they've seen the Justice Department
resists all efforts and accountability
even as it fails to hold its own
accountable and don't get them started
on the one sided media and yet they are
now witnessing unequal treatment in
special
counsel Robert Muller's probe yes the
former FBI director deserves credit for
smoking out the Russian trolls who
interfered in 2016
and one can argue he's obliged to pursue
any evidence of criminal acts even those
unrelated to Russia but what cannot be
justified is the one-sided nature of his
probe now I think there is truth to the
idea that DOJ should be looking into
campaign finance violations for example
by the Hillary Clinton campaign as
Kimberly Strasser will explain in a
second it looks like there were some of
those violations but those are kind of
going by the wayside however it is
important to recognize that Muller's
original purview was Russian collusion
and all crimes connected thereto and
when it comes to Russian collusion and
election interference all of that seems
to be coming from the Trump side of the
aisle so I'm not going to blame Muller
for the Beretta for the breadth of his
purview however you can say that the DOJ
outside of Millar ought to be looking
into campaign finance violations by the
Hillary team so here is what Kimberly
stressfull rights and I think that she's
correct she says if there's only one set
of rules whereas mr. Muller's referral
of a case against Hillary for America
federal law requires campaigns to
disclose the recipient and purpose of
any payments the Clinton campaign paid
fusion GPS to compile a dossier against
mr. Trump a document to be game the
basis of the Russian narrative mr.
Muller now investigates but the campaign
funneled the money to law firm perkins
coie which in turn paid fusion gps the
campaign falsely described the money as
payment for legal services the DNC did
the same a Perkins Coie spokesperson has
claimed that neither the Clinton
campaign nor the DNC was aware that
fusion gps had been hired to conduct the
research and maybe so but a lot of
lawyers here seems to have been ignoring
a clear statute presumably with the
intent of influencing an election and
she points out also that there have been
prosecutions under the Florence agent
Registration Act which is what has been
used to to nail Paul Manafort and Rick
gates people who are acting as
essentially emissaries of foreign powers
without registering as such but Strasser
points out under this standard where are
the charges against the principles of
fusion GPS who Senator Chuck Grassley
have said to look to have been lobbying
on behalf of powerful Russians against a
US sanctions law with its payments again
funneled through a law firm
there was a sideline to its dossier work
but mr. Muller usually has no issue with
sideline charges so I think that she's
correct that there should be more
investigation into perkins coie there
should be more investigations into the
DNC however it is imperative to note
just in the interest of intellectual
honesty that when it comes to
president Trump and Michael Cohen
Michael Cohen is the president's fixer
Michael cones the guy who turned on
Trump that's the reason we're talking
about all of this right now
the reason we're talking about all of
this right now is because Michael Cohen
was the guy who was funneling the money
and he has now turned on President Trump
and admitted criminal wrongdoing the
same has not held true with regard to
Perkins Coie that doesn't mean there
shouldn't be an investigation but there
is a slight difference in the amount of
evidence that has now been leveraged
against President Trump and against the
and against the Trump Organization with
all of that said the breaking news today
is that the Manhattan district
attorney's office is considering
pursuing criminal charges against the
Trump Organization and to senior company
officials in connection with Cohen's
hush-money payment to an adult film
actress according to two officials with
knowledge of the matter a state
investigation would Center on how the
company accounted for its reimbursement
to mr. Cohen for the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars he paid to the actress
Stephanie Clifford who has said she had
an affair with President Trump the
official said both officials stressed
the offices review of the matter is in
its earliest stages and prosecutors have
not yet made a decision on whether to
proceed so presumably this would involve
state charges against the Trump
Organization or its executives the Trump
Organization involves members of
President Trump's family so it could
start to get very ugly for a lot of
members of presidents from family it's
also true that the state Attorney
General in New York hates President
Trump and is more than interested in
going after the Trump Organization does
this look like selective prosecution
does it look like they're going a little
bit too deep maybe but we're gonna have
to see what charges arise other news
connected to this is that Alan
weiselberger who's president Trump's
longtime financial gatekeeper according
to The Wall Street Journal was granted
immunity by federal prosecutors for
providing information about Michael
Cohen in the criminal investigation into
hush money payments for two women during
the 2016 presidential campaign according
to people familiar with the matter
weiselberger is the chief financial
officer of the Trump Organization so
he's been granted immunity the Trump
Organization again involves members of
trumps family so this could
theoretically reach into Trump's family
it could also be that we're only finding
out about weiselberger becoming an
informant for the government because of
the Cohen case in other words what
Weissenberg had to offer was bad
material on Cohen not about members of
the Trump family we'll have to find out
about all of that none of this is
particularly good for the president of
course and then the biggest story
connected with all of this is this kind
of bombshell
that has now been reported by the New
York Times and a bunch of other and a
bunch of other outlets that the US
tabloid newspaper is the UK Guardian
reporting the National Enquirer kept a
safe containing documents on hush money
payments and other damaging stories it
killed as part of its cozy relationship
with President Trump leading up to the
2016 presidential election people
familiar with the arrangement have told
The Associated Press the detail came as
several media outlets reported on
Thursday that federal prosecutors had
granted immunity to the national
Enquirer's Chief David pecker
potentially laying bare his efforts to
protect his longtime friend Trump so if
there's a safe filled with material the
media are basically outside that safe
like safe crackers from a bad heist
movie trying to break in to find out
what exactly president Trump's secrets
were now there is a general sense as I
say that there's a little bit of
unfairness going on that on one side of
the aisle there's an investigation that
is going on into President Trump and all
of his associates that is
extraordinarily deep that is that is
extraordinarily detailed that takes an
enormous amount of effort and the
feeling is why are we taking all of this
effort on what may or may not be a
campaign finance violation and that
effort pre-existed the investigation
into cohen right we have this whole
Russian collusion investigation there's
a feeling like this fruit of the
poisonous tree
on the right that the Russian
investigation began it was it was begun
on the on Bad auspices that basically it
was exacerbated by a bunch of bad claims
from the DOJ and Obama associates and
Hillary Clinton associates that was
pushed forward by people like Peter
struck and then eventually after
President Trump fired Robert Muller and
after of Jeff Sessions recused himself
then a special counsel was appointed in
that special investigator then proceeded
to dig into Michael Cohen as an
extension into that and it all feels
just a little too much I think there is
some truth to that especially given the
fact that the Obama administration
routinely ignored crime that was
happening within its own ranks the Eric
Holder was held in contempt by Congress
for not turning over documents and the
President of the United States Barack
Obama presented him with executive
privilege he shielded him with executive
privilege so the feeling of unfairness
on one side of the aisle is absolutely
true and I think it's absolutely correct
as well that also two things can be true
at once it can be that unfairness is
happening here that Trump is being
pursued in a way Obama never would have
been that Michael Cohen is being pursued
in a way no
Obama associate ever would have been all
of that can be true and at the same time
it can also be true that Trump is
possibly guilty of some stuff and that
the people around him are guilty of some
stuff and have already pled guilty to
some stuff so you can feel the
unfairness and you can also say that
something corrupt went on here now the
question for the moral person but if you
get to a kind of root values the
question for the moral person is do you
think that this ought to result in
President Trump getting off the hook as
sort of a stop to the fact that the DOJ
has become thoroughly politicized or is
the answer that we have to start
enforcing the law somewhere and if the
law has to be enforced against people on
our own side well that's the way it's
gonna have to go in other words do two
wrongs make a right so we live in a
political sphere where it is more
important that both sides be treated
equally by being let off the hook for
corruption or is it better that we
actually start trying to reinstate some
semblance of law enforcement in our
system and it's hard it's hard because
it feels like we on the right are
constantly having to basically suggest
that we are on a higher plane that we
are that we are going to play by the
rules while the other side doesn't and
one of the great irritate it one of the
right irritations on Twitter and on
social media these days is you see all
of these fools on the left tweeting out
stuff about how the biggest scandal
under Obama was that he wore a tan suit
one time in a briefing that is nonsense
there's a list as long as my arm of
scandals in which the Obama
administration was involved ranging from
the IRS to Benghazi to fast and furious
to the Health and Human Services
corruption to the Veterans Affairs
scandal in there a bevy of scandals
under Barack Obama a bevy of them and
yet they were treated as nothing by the
media and so the natural tendency of
human beings is to fight back against
that by saying okay well if you guys
aren't gonna play by the rules we're not
gonna play by the rules either why
should we abide by the law if you guys
are not going to abide by the law and
then when you look at the way the media
treat these issues you also feel a
certain sense of unfairness because the
media are all over American media right
this this National Enquirer tabloid
paper that had a close relationship with
Trump but how many newspapers were
covering for Barack Obama
how many newspapers made clear that they
were gonna do Obama's bidding the LA
Times in the run-up to the 2008 election
had a tape of Rashid Khalidi who was an
actual member of the Palestine
Liberation Organization is a spoke
for terrorist group and Barack Obama
honoring him at an event and the LA
Times refused to release that publicly
so the same folks who are railing
against the National Enquirer for doing
Trump's dirty work as well they should
be a lot of them were doing Obama's
dirty work at when Obama was president
so it feels unfair on that and also in
just a second I want to talk about what
the predictable ramifications of that
should be but first let's talk about the
software you use at your company when
you're dealing with a real
head-scratcher having a go-to person on
call is a no brainer and that certainly
holds true when it comes to figuring out
what software you should be using your
company to make your company more
efficient software advice has done all
the research for you their team of
advisors can point you in the right
direction so you can start working more
effectively right away and it's
absolutely free just go to software
advice calm /ban you answer a few short
questions about your business and then
you'll be connected with an advisor to
discuss the best software options for
your needs talking to an advisor takes
just 10 minutes or less whether you're a
medical professional a construction
manager and HR pro software advice will
save you time and help you make a more
informed decision you know that if you
look across the country the sort of
software a lot of businesses use they're
using like software from 1995 and they
don't and they think oh well how much
time it's gonna take me to relearn
software reinstall the software that's
cuz you don't know anything about
software which is why you need the folks
over at software advice they're ready to
be your on-call go-to team to help you
figure out business software in minutes
for free go check them out right now
software advice.com slash been to get
started that software at vice.com slash
men's connect with an advisor for free
software advice.com slash pen so as I
say you look at the media and the media
who are ripping on National Enquirer as
is well deserved the same media who rip
on fox news all day for being
quote-unquote in the pocket of President
Trump those media are in the pocket of
the left and have been for decades and
it feels unfair all this feels unfair
and that's driving a level of support
for President Trump in spite of the
credible allegations of corruption
inside the Trump campaign I have
sympathy for this position I do there's
an emotional sympathy that accrues to
this it feels like the DOJ let Hillary
Clinton off the hook it feels like the
DOJ Leppa rock obama off the hook it
feels like Eric Holder and Loretta Lynch
basically acted as Barack Obama's great
protectors while Jeff Sessions is not
doing the same for the President of the
United States and so why can't we just
play by their rules right that was in
fact one of the premises
of the of the Trump campaign was they're
not gonna play by the rules at the
markets of Queensbury rules let's just
nominate the guy who's not gonna play by
any rules at all who smashes every rule
we'll get the bull in the china shop
he'll go in there he will destroy all
the rules and then Trump won and it felt
like destroying the rules was the only
way to win and I think that that is a
predictable effect of the left's
decision to basically buck every rule
for decades for as long as I've been
alive and then insist that the right be
held to precisely those rules we're
seeing the same thing with the
impeachment talk today all the same
folks who are against Bill Clinton's
impeachment him now turned around and
said they are very much in favor of Bill
of Donald Trump's impeachment on similar
or lesser grounds it feels unfair it
feels like partisan hackery
but the question is is the solution to
partisan hackery more partisan hackery
is the country better off if Republicans
if conservatives start basically shying
away from the notion of a law
enforcement doing its job just because
the left has shied away from that is
that a recipe for a better politics is
that a recipe for a better country is
the way that we heal from all of this to
basically go along with the left's
premise that law enforcement should be
used as a tool of those in power or
should we recognize that law enforcement
should have a certain level of
Independence that law enforcement should
prosecute crimes as they come up maybe
that's the case we should be making to
the American people maybe the case we
should be making is look if this were
under Obama here to shut this stuff down
already
because the Democrats are more corrupt
but when Republicans get in power then
Republicans get prosecuted because
Republicans are willing to let law
enforcement go forward that seems to me
like a fairly moral case that ought to
be made and honestly if the American
people want to stand up against
corruption the answer to that is to
elect people who you know are not going
to stand in the way of investigation of
corruption that means don't elect
Democrats now I want to talk about
President Trump's response to all of
this because President Trump
representing as he does the sort of Ed
of the Republican Party and also
representing a guy who really loves
himself a lot he's very angry Jeff
Sessions Jeff sessions is the Attorney
General and he's angry at Jeff Sessions
because Jeff Sessions has not acted as
eric holder or loretta lynch did he has
not stood there and protected president
Trump and president Trump's associates
from investigation into corrupt
activities so yesterday President Trump
was on TV with Fox and Friends and he
went off on Jeff Sessions in pretty
harsh terms it's a very
very sad a Jeff Sessions recused himself
which he shouldn't have done or he
should have told me even my enemies say
that Jeff Sessions should have told you
that he was going to recuse himself and
then you wouldn't have put him in he
took the job and then he said I'm going
to recuse myself I said what kind of a
man is this and by the way he was on the
campaign you know the owner isn't I gave
him the job because I felt lousy he was
an original supporter okay the answer is
he's the kind of man who does the
honorable thing by recusing himself I'm
very much in Jeff Sessions corner here
as the Attorney General of the United
States your job is to uphold the law of
the land in the Constitution of the
United States it is not to be the
president's protector I don't see how we
on the conservative right can complain
about Eric Holder if we just want our
own Eric Holder I don't see how we can
complain about Loretta Lynch meeting
with Bill Clinton if we just want our
own Loretta Lynch and I understand the
tendency to say listen they're corrupt
why can't we play by their rules they're
not playing by our rules so why can't we
play by their rules but I don't think
that that is a recipe for a better
country I think that's a recipe for a
worse country
Jeff Sessions finally fired back against
the president he issued a statement on
the basis of these statements he says I
took control of the Justice Department
the day I was sworn in which is why
we've had unprecedented success at
effectuating the President's agenda one
that protects the safety and security of
the American people reduces violent
crime enforces our immigration laws
promotes economic growth and advances
religious liberty well I am Attorney
General the actions of the Department of
Justice will not be improperly
influenced by political considerations I
demand the highest standards and where
they are not met I take action however
no nation has a more talented more
dedicated group of law enforcement
investigators and prosecutors than the
United States I am proud to serve with
them and proud of the work we have done
and successfully advancing the rule of
law the key line here is while I am
Attorney General the actions of the DOJ
will not be improperly influenced by
political considerations as jeff
sessions doing what he's supposed to do
which is he is saying listen I'm not
going to be pressured into doing
anything here right the way this works
is that I abide by the law and this is
correct but again I think there's a
battle that's now been breaking out on
the right I think it's a year's long
battle at this point as to how much of
your morality how much of decency are
you going to sacrifice for victory if
you feel like we have to and is it
really a victory if you sacrifice that
morality or is it have we won anything
let's say that let's
the Jeff Sessions became a flat for
president Trump let's say that he fired
Robert MOA and he became a flak for
president Trump just defending him
against all comers is that a win for the
country is that a win for the right in
one sense it's a win for the right
because President Trump experiences less
blowback presumably although I'm not
even sure that's true because the media
is so much to the left but on the other
hand what exactly is the right fighting
for if not the idea that the rule of law
applies to everyone this is why I'm
sympathetic to Kimberly strassens
argument more than I am to president
Trump's argument I don't think the
solution here is for Jeff Sessions to
suddenly become a political actor I do
think the solution here is for the DOJ
to look into malfeasance on all sides
that it shouldn't just be on one side
and that if that requires more
investigators it requires more
investigators like the case against
unfairness is a strong one but the
solution to unfairness I don't think is
more in fairness unfortunately there's
some on the right who really believe
that they have to go along with the
president's whims here Lindsey Graham is
one of these folks senator from South
Carolina who a long time ago was very
anti Trump now he's very Pro Trump
obviously and he came out and he sort of
split the difference he says he thinks
that sessions did the right thing by
refusing but if the president fires
sessions he'll go along with it every
president deserves an attorney general
they have confidence in as to Jeff
Sessions I've never met a finer man he
was a great senator he's great lawyer I
think he's been a good Attorney General
but this is not working so I hope the
relationship gets better if it doesn't I
would imagine the president is going to
look for a new Attorney General because
what's going on is unsustainable I'm not
blaming anybody I love Jeff Sessions but
from my point of view the country is not
being well served with this much
friction I mean that's it as a breach in
the wall right there because Republican
senators were basically saying if Jeff
Sessions goes we're not appointing a new
Attorney General it's just gonna be
whatever happens from there my trap
session but there's Lindsey Graham
basically saying if from fire sessions
then we'll go along with that which
again do you think that's gonna renounce
Republicans electoral benefit the
American people can sense when it feels
like people are being corrupt I think
that you know we have the sense on the
right that Barack Obama didn't pay a
price for his corruption that Barack
Obama didn't pay a price for Eric Holder
and Loretta Lynch except for the fact
that Republicans have been in control of
Congress since 2010 and now run the
presidency so the American people can in
fact feel corruption and extending the
corruption
the other side of the aisle is not an
actual solution hey speaking of which
we'll talk about Duncan Hunter and the
case against Duncan Hunter I also want
to talk a little bit about media
malfeasance and corruption because it's
pretty insane in just a second we'll
talk about president a little more about
President Trump as well but first let's
talk about your impending doom so you
will die at some point hopefully it'll
be a little while but when you do plots
you're gonna want to make sure that your
family was taken care of if not then not
only are they gonna be sad you're dead
but also they're not gonna have money to
pay for your funeral well that's why you
need policy genius go over to policy
genius and go check out their life
insurance rates right now
life insurance rates are the lowest
they've been in 20 years the best time
to buy is right now the best place to
buy is policy genius calm policy genius
is the easy way to compare life
insurance online in just five minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renters insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you've been putting off
getting life insurance there is no
reason to put it off any longer go to
policy genius com get quotes apply in
minutes it is that easy you can do it
right now and you should because the
rates are their lowest in 20 years
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare it and buy life insurance again
policy genius calm the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
them out right now policy genius comment
let them know that we sent you okay so
president Trump is you know very much in
line with with Lindsey Graham obviously
he's very upset with Jeff Sessions he
had a bunch of tweets this morning about
Jeff session so this is going to come to
a head here's what President Trump had a
tweety tweeted Department of Justice
would that be improperly influenced by
political considerations Jeff this is
great what everyone wants so look into
all of the corruption on the other side
including deleted emails coming lies and
leaks
Mulla conflicts mccabe struck page or a
few things that are actually necessary
to mention about here is that we only
know about Peter struck we only know
about McCabe we only know about about
Lisa Paige we only know about all of
this stuff because of an Inspector
General report from the Department of
Justice so it's not like the DOJ isn't
looking into this stuff or hasn't looked
into this stuff and if Trump wants to
order an investigation he does have the
capacity to do that now I haven't seen
the information jeff sessions has seen I
assume the president Trump has if
president from
feels the evidence is that strong he
should order an investigation right now
also if the president really feels like
all this stuff was really criminal you
know what he can do declassify all of it
remember the president does have the
power does he classify all of this
information so when he complains about
FISA abuse
Christopher's steel and his phoney and
corrupt dossier the Clinton Foundation
illegal surveillance of Trump campaign
Russian collusion by Dems and so much
more open up the papers and documents
without redaction come on Jeff you can
do it the country is waiting Jeff
Sessions is not the head of the
executive branch Donald J Trump is the
head of the executive branch if he wants
the papers opened up without redaction
all he has to do is declassify them he's
not doing that which suggests to me and
that his legal advisers have seen this
stuff and it doesn't all cut in the
direction that President Trump actually
wants it to cut in so how much of this
is fulmination for public purposes I
don't know but I'm getting frankly a
little frustrated with all the abuse of
Jeff Sessions from the right
particularly I don't think Jeff Sessions
is doing a bad job I think he's doing a
fine job and this this notion that Jeff
Sessions is somehow a tool of the left
when he was the first senator to endorse
Donald Trump he first okay don't talk
about he's not loyal to Trump he was the
first senator to endorse Donald Trump
back when Donald Trump didn't look like
he had a prayer okay this idea that
sessions is some sort of stool this is
some sort of stool pigeon for Hillary
Clinton I just I find it insulting
meanwhile the corruption on the right
side of the aisle continues to be a
public issue Duncan Hunter the
representative from California he has
been accused along with his wife of
basically embezzling $250,000 and using
it for personal purposes and then
apparently telling people that he was
using the money to benefit wounded vets
in some cases really ugly stuff well
last night he was down with martha
maccallum on fox news and he proceeded
to blame his wife so this is all going
great so are you saying that it's more
her fault than your fault
well I'm saying when I when I went to
Iraq in 2003 the first time I gave her
power of attorney and she handled my
finances throughout my entire military
career and that continued on when I got
into Congress because I was gone five
days a week on home for two so why and
she was also the camp the campaign
manager so whatever she did on that
that'll be that'll be looked at too I'm
sure but but I didn't do it I didn't
spend any money illegally I didn't I did
not use
campaign money is especially for wounded
warriors stuff this is going great so
I'm gonna blame my wife perfect that's
that's gonna be the excuse yeah I can't
see how this goes off the rails how
about this how about we praise law
enforcement for doing its job and we
recommend the law enforcement when
Democrats take power or arm power ought
to be doing the same job again there are
electoral consequences to not abiding by
the law democrats found that out in 2010
2012 2014 and 2016 republicans are gonna
find that out if they go the way of
democrats and start using law
enforcement in order to shield all of
their friends meanwhile let's talk about
the hypocrisy of some in the media
because it truly is astonishing so over
the last few days there's been a lot of
talk about molly Tibbets molly Tibbets
20 year old college student in iowa who
was essentially picked up off the street
and murdered by an illegal immigrant she
was just jogging this illegal immigrant
drove up alongside her in a truck he
actually cat called her she tried to run
away from him she threatened to call the
police he grabbed her he killed her he
threw in the trunk and then he dumped
her in a cornfield in the middle of Iowa
is just an awful awful story and this
has become a national issue for a couple
of reasons some good and some bad
and I want to discuss whether it's moral
to make this a national issue because
when there's a school shooting there are
some of us on the right who say the
media's attempt to make every school
shooting into the jumping off point for
a gun control discussion without any of
the facts being in that's immoral when
we have these town hall events in
parkland where Marco Rubio is called a
murderer in front of a throng of people
all cheering and baying for his blood
that is not a that that is a bad thing
right there they're a bunch of us who
say that that is inappropriate but when
it comes to the Molly Tibbets case then
we're a little softer well I think that
there are some distinctions to be drawn
between the Molly Tibbets cases and some
of the school shooting stuff here's the
basic analysis I think that there there
are a couple reasons why you should talk
about cases like Molly Tibbets one case
is obviously that people who are
murdered ought to be talked about and
this holds true whether it's somebody
who's murdered in Chicago or whether it
is a girl who was murdered in Iowa the
media tend to focus on more attractive
victims that's just the way the media
works this is a pretty young woman who
was killed and unfortunately the media
feel they can get more clicks when they
cover Molly Tibbets that's one reason
the other reason that but but the reason
that she really deserves attention is
because the media pay outsized attention
to victims they think push their
particular narrative and then they
ignore victims who they think do not
push that particular narrative so they
covered Molly Tibbets Wald
until it turned out that the illegal
that the killer was an illegal immigrant
at which point they still covered Molly
Tibbets but they mostly covered the fact
that the right was pointing out that
Molly Tibbets his killer was an illegal
immigrant they're not gonna have any
town halls in Iowa about illegal
immigration after Molly Tibbets was
killed by an illegal immigrant they're
not going to do that if she'd been
killed in a school shooting there would
be a town hall in Iowa tomorrow with CNN
in the lead there's no question that
that would be the case so when is it
actually appropriate to talk about
policy well it's appropriate to talk
about policy when three factors have
been fulfilled I think first when we
know the actual circumstance of a given
incident so we actually know what
happened one of the problems with a lot
of the school shooting talk is that we
don't actually know what happened some
somebody shoots up a school we don't
know where they got the gun we don't
know anything about the shooter and
before you can even before the bodies
are even cold before before we even know
whether people are alive or dead
everybody jumps to a gun control
conversation on Twitter that's
inappropriate because you actually need
more facts to talk about policy in this
case the fact that this guy was an
illegal immigrant it does raise one
policy issue which is are we properly
enforcing our laws but we actually don't
know why he was in the country how he
got into the country what laws would
have had to be more strictly enforced in
order to keep him out of the country we
don't know any of those things so I
think that it is premature to talk
policy with regard to this guy second
you should talk about an instance when
the circumstances are representative of
a broader trend there is there is crime
among the illegal immigrants well
there's arguments about whether that
crime rate is higher or lower than the
domestic population but the bottom line
is that if one crime is committed by an
illegal immigrants then that is one
crime too many considering that that
illegal immigrant should not be in the
country so I think it's fair to talk
about it from that perspective and third
you can talk about policy when the
policy recommend that logically concerns
the trend and would have stopped the
incident question this is where I say
I'm not sure we have enough information
about Molly's hits yet so in what
situation should we cover the Molly
Tibbets thing we should cover it by
recognizing that the media are
completely unjust in their own coverage
of these issues that Molly Tibbets will
not be covered by CNN in the same way as
school shooting would be covered by CNN
I think that's a perfectly fair
political point to make on the back of
the Molly Tippit's case I think it is
also perfectly fair to talk about
illegal immigration and the costs
thereof in terms of crime because we
know this guy was an illegal immigrant
however when it comes to policy making
I'm not sure we can actually talk about
what policies ought to be implemented
yet because we don't know how the guy
got in the country
how long he'd been in the country had he
been deported deported previously had he
committed other crimes we don't know
enough about that at this point however
the media's anger at even discussing the
issue is wildly outsized and
hypocritical considering how much they
are willing to cover every single school
shooting up the wazoo so here's quest
Chris Cuomo on CNN going after president
Trump for talking about Mali Tibbets
Kate Steinle now Mali Tibbets they put
their faces out there almost like
campaign posters and the political pitch
follows soon thereafter if you're not
with the president on how to deal with a
legal entrance and really his hostility
toward all immigrants you are
disrespecting these victims and their
families and you're putting others in
danger I don't accept that
okay so Chris Cuomo is not making the
worst argument here the problem is that
he's made precisely the reverse argument
when it comes to guns everyone on CNN
hey that's right just take all of the
things he said and flip them around so
it's about school shootings and now he
sounds like a hypocrite because Chris
Cuomo and CNN have said that if you
don't agree with them on gun control
it's because you don't care enough about
the dead kids this is one of my pet
peeves in politics is when people do
this routine so I think that it's it's a
mistake to say that folks on the Left
don't care about people who are killed
by illegal immigrants but it is fair to
talk about border policy once all the
facts are in and it's certainly fair to
point out the hypocrisy of the media
that is willing to ignore crimes like
this in order to focus in on crimes that
push their political agenda in a more
thoroughgoing way Geraldo Rivera does
the same thing on Fox News obviously
he's a pro illegal immigrant figure and
so he's very upset that people are
talking about illegal immigration he's
not here legally we are putting that
spin we are we at this network are
putting that spin on this story this is
a murder story this is not an
immigration story this is feeding the
false impression that this population
increases violent crime it is a false
right to make that point as well okay
well you can use this case to make the
point that any crime committed by an
illegal immigrant who shouldn't be here
is a mistake by federal law enforcement
already have laws on the books right we
and by the way people on the right make
the same argument about guns that we
already have gun control laws on the
book so if there's a shooting and
somebody violated the law in order to
get a gun then law enforcement should
have done its job so the right is
actually relatively consistent here now
there are a group of people on the right
who are making hay while the Sun shines
they're turning this into a well if we
can make Mali tip it's a household name
and if we can claim the Democrats don't
care about the death of Mali Tibbets
well then we can make political hay I
don't think that the evidence is in for
that and I don't like that tactic very
much I don't like that tactic that said
there are some people on the Left who
have demonstrated some pretty
cold-hearted stuff when it comes to Mali
Tibbets and I've talked about
commentator on MSNBC who basically just
dismissed the her death as some girl but
I think that's minority viewpoint there
are political differences on this issue
and those are political differences we
should hash out but I want to be careful
about how we handle stories like Mali
Tibbets she deserves coverage because
every murder victim deserves coverage we
can discuss illegal immigration but we
have to wait for all the facts to come
in but we should certainly point out the
hypocrisy of the media that will jump to
discussing any issue so long as it is
not an issue with which they disagree
okay just a second I want to talk about
some actual serious issues in America
like trend lines that look really bad
that are being obscured by sort of the
daily headlines then we'll get to the
mailbag but first you're gonna have to
go over to Taylor wire calm for $9.99 a
month you can get the rest of this show
live the rest of Andrew Klavan show live
there are some Michael Moses show live
be part of our mailbag we're doing our
mailbag in like 1 minute here if you
want to ask me questions live all you
have to do is head over there right now
and start asking your questions after
you subscribe for $99 ear you get all
that plus they leftist here's how to
recalled tumblr that is a cheaper price
than the monthly subscription and you
get this this magnificent piece of
ceramic I think it's made of ceramic go
check it out right now
it is it is made of metal I know
whatever it's great check it out you'll
love it
so that's that's our pitch also help
support the show we always appreciate
that I mean you you help us make the
show possible and make sure that you
subscribe over YouTube and over at
iTunes that way you can get our Sunday
special this week Sunday special is clay
Travis we have a couple more coming up
that are just fantastic go check that
out right now we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
by the way final point on the media if
you don't believe in the political bias
of the media all you had to do is watch
Chris Cuomo like a fool of himself last
night interviewing Kellyanne Conway so
Kellyanne Conway was out there making
the case for the President on a variety
of issues and Chris Cuomo just will not
allow her to get a word in edgewise it's
really a horrible performance by Cuomo
who's now considering himself sort of
Jim Acosta but bigger and weirder and
here's what he had to say what are you
tweeting about we play them all the time
I'll play his voice saying to Michael
Cohen what are we gonna do and then how
are you gonna do it what do you what do
you mean about finance play the tape
okay so he is just great you know the
just great interviewing skills by Chris
Cuomo I can't imagine why people think
that he is biased all of this sort of
back and forth in American politics is
obscuring some relatively big stories
that we are missing because these are
the trend lines we should be watching
Terrance Jeffrey has a piece over at CNS
news.com today that says that fifty two
point one percent of children in America
within households getting means-tested
government assistance he says in 2016
according to the most recent data from
the Census Bureau there were
approximately 74 million people in the
United States under 18 38 million of
them 52.1% resided in households in
which one or more persons received
benefits from a means-tested government
program that includes Supplemental
Nutrition Assistance Program that's food
stamps Medicaid public housing
supplement Supplemental Security income
the special supplemental nutrition
program for women infants and children
Temporary Assistance for Needy Families
and the National School Lunch Program
this table indicates that there are
approximately 320 million people living
in the United States of these 115
million people lived in a household that
received means-tested assistance that
doesn't mean every person in the
household received the aid but it means
that one or more persons living in the
household did people under 18 were the
most likely to receive all of this aid
we are creating a system of government
dependents that's going to be very
difficult for us to recover from and it
is not sustainable long run the only way
that you're gonna be able to sustain
anything resembling a free market
economy is if we is if we lower the
burden on public services and the way to
do that is not only a thriving economy
but deregulation and also an increase
in public charity a bettering of our
education system attempts by private
industry to actually go into
underprivileged areas and and hire
people and educate people if that
doesn't happen then we are moving very
quickly toward a huge government so soft
socialism a lot of socialist systems
built on top of a fading capitalist
system think of the American system not
as a socialist system or a capitalist
system but is basically a clown on
stilts the stilts are capitalism the
clown and socialist programs and at a
certain point if the clown gets too fat
the stilts just break and that's
basically what we are on the verge of
here in the United States we're not
quite there yet
thank God capitalism is incredibly
robust thank God business is still able
to generate enough revenue to cover some
of this although we are borrowing at
extraordinary exorbitant rates but there
will come a time when those stilts break
and the socialism just starts to
the economy in a major way and we're
accelerating that we're moving in the
wrong direction
there's a poll out today showing a vast
majority of Americans 70 percent support
Medicare for all they don't know what
that means they don't understand what
the cost of that is but we continue to
think that government is the solution to
all of our problems that is a bigger
broader trend than any of the stuff
that's happening with regard to
corruption or or any of the rest of it
okay so in a second let's do it let's
you know let's jump in the mailbag so
let's do some mailbag right here okay
let's go to John okay John says hi Ben
I'm a freshman at Purdue University with
a question on socialism yes I know it's
evil and horrible anyway in my
experience in middle and high school I
was taught in detail about the horrors
of far right wing Nazi Germany but never
in the same detail about those of other
socialist regimes like China or the USSR
considering that those powers were just
as oppressive for often the same
motivations why was I never taught this
in school is there actually a
significant difference between Nazi
socialism and Soviet Chinese socialism
when did the notion that Nazi Germany
was far right-wing become widely
distributed I know that history is often
written by the winners but if this is
true how come the USSR and China are not
vilified in the same way as Nazi Germany
any answers to one or all these
questions is appreciated okay so here's
the answer and I've puzzled over this
too people will still our Che Guevara
t-shirts but if they wore a Himmler
t-shirt people would rightly say that
person is a piece of crap Che Guevara
was a communist terrorist who murdered
innocent people and people wear his
t-shirt around on college campuses
communism is not seen in the same way as
Nazism specifically because of the
racial components of Nazism that is why
is the real answer hey the reason that
Mussolini is seen as a buffoon and not
as a as a tyrannical evil dictator so
much is because he was less racist than
Hitler basically that the the racism
that was embedded in the Nazi program is
what made Nazism particularly toxic to
those on the left the reason for this is
that the media actually have a soft spot
for socialism up until the Soviet Union
collapse there are a lot of people in
the United States on the Left who are
quite warm toward the idea of more
Marxist American governments they might
have wanted a socialist to check on
full-on communism but they were kind of
warm toward the USSR remember in the
1930s the USSR was promoted by the left
in the United States as the wave of the
future
HG Wells in Britain was talking about
how the USSR was going to be the new way
that we did things that scientific
socialism was the way that the world was
going to run and they never really quite
gave up on that I was talking about this
with a friend of mine who happens to be
kind of on the left and we were
discussing the fact that on the right
the right will actually excise Nazis
from its ranks there's a story this week
about the Claremont Institute there's a
guy named Charles Johnson who was who
was basically expressing white
supremacist sentiments on one of their
list serves and Claremont just shut it
down they shut down the entire listserv
because they said we're not interacting
with this guy and the left said look at
these white supremacist who have
infiltrated Claremont well Claremont
shut down the listserv when's the last
time somebody on the left was actually
excised for their ideas not for
promoting violence for their ideas
they're open communists who write for
major publications on the left there are
no open Nazis writing for major
publications on the right they're not
okay that's because the right does a
better job of policing its own ideology
the right doesn't better job of policing
the the folks who are sort of on the
fringes now I still think we should do a
better job but the left has never
policed any of this stuff now the reason
that Nazi Germany is considered
quote-unquote far-right is because the
Nazis arose in a context in Europe in
which the left was the Reds like the
actual communists backed by the Soviet
Union and in Germany the coalition
government that was put together and
that led to Hitler's rise was a
coalition of anti-communist and Hitler
was anti-communist the the Nazis were
anti-communist but they also believed in
this big government redistributionist
program they believed in also what was
called basically economic fascism this
idea that the government could regulate
business incredibly heavily that could
benefit certain businesses at the
expense of
other businesses that run business from
the top without actually nationalizing
all the resources of those businesses
that's the difference between economic
fascism or state-sponsored capitalism as
you now see in China China's economic
system now looks a lot more like Nazi
Germany's economic system than like the
Soviet Union's economic system and
that's because they're using capitalism
but a state-sponsored capitalism
nationalization of resources regulations
on certain businesses benefiting friends
of government and all the rest so Nazi
Germany was considered right-wing by
European standards but and is deeply
dishonest when folks on the Left in the
United States say that Nazi Germany was
a right-wing group by American standards
that's just nonsense the right in the
United States is not for nationalization
of industry or top-down control of
industry the right in the United States
is not for racial classification the
right in the United States is about
limited government and god-given rights
none of which or any part of the Nazi
platform should communism be treated
with the same toxicity as Nazism you bet
it should the only real difference in
terms of the in terms of the
classification of evil is that you could
say Nazi Germany was more evil because
there was this heavy racial component
which is an additional evil and
particularly relevant evil in the United
States where racial issues have divided
America for a very long time Patrick
says hey Ben I love listening to music
in my free time but I've come to realize
lately I could be listening to an
audiobook or podcast instead how do you
balance learning and leisure well you
know what I realize I tend to lean
toward learning but at the same time
I'll go for a week without listening to
music and I'll realize how I'm depressed
and then I realized the reason I'm
depressed is because I haven't actually
taken enough time for music so I think
that you have to let your brain rest
sometimes and that's what music is for
Veronica says hey Ben how did you
actually meet Knowles and Clavin have
you ever actually met Matt Walsh in
person I have Mountain melt Walsh in
person I think once he came out to our
offices a few months ago
I'm trying member when I first met
Andrew Clinton I believe I first met
Andrew Cleveland he was working at PJTV
doing these short videos and klevens a
really literate guy we got to talking
and it would became quite friendly from
there
I meant Knowles at a dinner party at
clavin's house and Knowles was
particularly pretentious talking a lot
about Yale that night and so I decided
hey why not give that guy a show it's my
everlasting regret so that's basically
how I met those guys and Daniel says hey
Ben
huge fan I want to ask is there benefit
to using executive privilege on Michael
Kohn just like Obama used it on Eric
Hall
I believe hoping to see you run for
president one day well executive
privilege only applies to folks who are
operating under the auspices of the
president's it doesn't actually apply to
anyone the president deals with so the
office of the presidency does not cover
everything that the president does in
his life so if I am committing some sort
of drug crime with somebody as the
president of the United States and that
person is operating not as a member of
the government executive privilege
doesn't extend to those crimes that are
happening outside of government it
really extends my understanding is to
the constitutional purview of the
presidency Michael Cohen was not an
employee of the government he was
working for Donald J Trump in his
private capacity not in Donald J Trump
as presidents of the United States DJ
says hi Ben how do you rectify your
beliefs in the biblical accounts of
creation with the scientific theories of
evolution of the Big Bang if they can
coexist how do we know which parts of
the Bible to interpret is poetic I also
wanted to say I became a dad a few
months ago in love when you talk about
fatherhood Thanks
well I appreciate it um there are a
couple of good books that I that I
really like about evolution and the Big
Bang and God gerald Schroeder's when my
favorite authors on this I do believe
that the theory of evolution fits
actually quite well with sort of the
story of creation that's laid out in
Genesis in terms of the ordering and the
timing and as far as the Big Bang the
Big Bang lays out much closer to the
beginning of Genesis than it did to
Aristotelian physics that suggests that
the universe has always existed in its
current state the Big Bang suggests that
out of nothing God created everything
and that looks a lot like the Big Bang
which is why there are so many people
now trying to create theories of
multiple universes because they don't
like the consequences of the fact that
science looks a lot like what the Bible
lays out as far as knowing which parts
of the Bible to interpret as poetic I
think that the stuff that deals with
human action particularly is not poetic
the stuff that deals with nature I think
you can fairly say is poetic I think
that the the beginning of Genesis is
pretty clearly meant in in a far more
metaphorical sense I don't believe there
was an actual garden where a snake
talked to a man like I don't think
that's actually what happened in a
literal sense I my there there's a lot
of debate in Jewish circles actually
about where the Bible begins to get
historically accurate like where it's
actually now talking about historically
accurate people and the general
consensus from what I understand I know
Jonathan Sacks has said this is
basically and once you get to a bruh
now you're talking about an actual
historical story and before that at a
certain level of metaphor that's that's
kind of inter wolven throughout the
story I tend to believe that myself
Jessica says good morning legal question
is always my understanding the ignorance
of the law is not an excuse and
committing a crime certainly not for a
common citizen why is it that in the
political sphere there's a focus on the
need for intent or awareness as in the
recent examples with Hillary or Trump
thanks for all you do and your team do
in the era of fake news she asked me to
read thick news in a trump voice okay so
here so the answer is that there are
certain crimes that require intent the
level of requisite intent is always a
matter of debate
so it's not that you have to have had
subjective intent to do things it's that
a reasonably a reasonable person could
determine that you had intent to commit
the crime so we use intent in all sorts
of crimes particularly the criminal
sphere so when it comes to torts you
generally don't have to have as much
intent like if I'm just walking around
swinging my arm in front of me and I hit
you then that is not something that you
have to show intent if I'm negligent you
don't have to show intense that's more
of a strict liability standard if
however I commit let's say that I kill
somebody we now have to determine what
level of intent I was using did I kill
somebody by accident like I was just
walking around and and suddenly I
tripped forward and in order to stop my
fall I pushed somebody into oncoming
traffic that looks like manslaughter it
may not even be a crime at all whereas
if I just walked up behind the guy and
shoved him in front of a subway that is
first-degree murder so intent is an
element of a lot of crimes particularly
in criminal law and you have to
determine whether there was intent to
violate the law now ignorance of the law
is not necessarily sufficient to get rid
of the intent question you can also have
reckless ignorant of the law and that's
that's more where Trump would lie it's
not that Trump didn't know about
campaign finance so let's say let's say
this let's say that Trump went to
Michael Khan he said listen I want you
to take care of this and the implication
was Michael Khan is a lawyer he's gonna
abide by the law it's his job to make
sure that I'm abiding by the law
well then Trump has not demonstrated the
requisite intent let's say that Trump
went to Michael Cohen
and he said to Michael Khan listen I
don't care how you do this it doesn't
matter to me how you do this right
legally illegally whatever you do don't
tell me about it just go ahead and do it
that is now intent to violate the law so
it's not that you have to know
everything about the law it's that did
Donald Trump have a right to trust in
his lawyer to abide by the law that's
actually a fairly solid defense as far
as intents in the Hillary case it's a
pet peeve of mine that there are so many
folks who pretend that intent was a
requisite part of the crime it was not a
requisite part of the crime she
obviously intended to set up a server
she obviously didn't intended to put
information on there they added this
element of intent that she had to intend
to expose information to foreign powers
that is not part of the law that is not
part of the law and that's why I think
Hillary should have been prosecuted Mike
says hey Ben I'm a devoted member of the
Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints is it Mormon I deeply respect
your example of religious strength and
courage I was wondering what experiences
you've had in your life that have made
you so strong religiously I love the
show keep up the good work so you know
I've always had sort of a deep and
abiding faith in God I can't really
explain you know specific instances I I
don't really think there are a lot of
instances that you know I'd want to talk
about they're kind of private to me that
I didn't want to talk about where I
where I was suddenly like oh well God
exists I don't think that's really how
it was I've always just had a I think we
all walk around with a baseline level of
beliefs in certain things the
consistency of the laws of the universe
for example you know that gravity exists
you know that there are certain
consequences certain actions my belief
in God lies in the idea that there is a
rule book from God that tells you that
if you act in a certain way you are much
more likely to succeed than if you act
in a different way and just as I would
have the faith in an author who told me
that if I eat certain things I was more
likely to be healthy I have a lot of
faith in an author who says that if
human beings act in a particular way
they are more likely to succeed in life
if they act in a non particular way they
are more likely to fail and if they act
in one way they're more likely to be
moral human beings better human beings
I sort of take religion
the proof of the truth of religion or
the decency of religion the importance
of religion lies to me a lot less in the
text of the religion or even the the
story of the religion than in the
effects of the religion which is why for
example you don't see me doing a lot of
analysis of the Quran on the show I
don't talk about when I talk about
radical Islam I don't start citing
Quranic verses because I think that we
can fairly adjudicate the relevance and
decency of religion by the action of its
practitioners over time and that that's
that's a better way of gauging the
veracity of religion and I think the way
that you gauge veracity and faith in God
is not just faith in
faith in God is different from the
belief that God exists belief that God
exists you can ration out intellect you
can rationalize intellectually and I
think there's some good arguments for it
faith in God is a belief that God is is
has a plan for the universe whether you
understand it or not and you have faith
in God just like you have faith in your
spouse or you have faith in your father
or you have faith in your business
partner and that is that there's a cause
and effect in the universe and that God
does what he promises he is going to do
that's what faith and God really means
and to me I've always always felt that
I've always believed that now and you
know it's not up to God to let me down
it's whether I let God down final
question here let's see Rachel says hi
Ben first off only love your show one
thing that gets me through the day so I
think your impressions are hilarious I
was wondering what your favorite
impression to do is my personal favorite
is Bernie Sanders so yeah Bernie is a
lot of fun I really like doing Bernie
Sanders Sonia also is a big fan of the
Bernie Sanders whenever we talk about
the pudding and the sugary prints and
the redistribution of it's always fun to
refund Bernie Sanders because he says
crazy things but he also looks kind of
crazy doing it and his hands move in
various different directions so Bernie
Sanders is I do enjoy Bernie Sanders I
enjoy doing Chris Matthews Chris
Matthews a lot of fun to do so all right
hurry up Maddie's got the morning tell
me the show right I'll run book little
crazy and I just got a safe day and
Michael Isikoff what do you say they say
should Trump be burnt the steaks of
which I don't know talak which is what I
saw what's your movie Blair Witch
Project good movie it's a anything you
can do sort of stream of consciousness
is a lot of fun but yeah IIIi love all
of my I won't say I love all of my
impressions equally because I think some
of them are just bad I think I think
that my Trump is mediocre at best I
think my Obama is quite good it's very
underrated my Obama my Obama is pretty
strong and my Obama is that thank you
Alex yeah Alex just piped in from the
back saying that hit that my Obama is
strong thank you Alex and Alex his beard
I appreciate it with with Obama the key
to doing an Obama impersonation is that
you first start off speaking a little
bit clipped a little bit slowly and then
as you approach the end of the sentence
you sort of gradually speed up and the
voice goes up just kind of gradually
slowly speed it up
all right that's that's how you do a
good amount of my impersonation there's
also with
the fun with Trump is always trying to
get down the the actual patter of
President Trump that's that's the part
with Trump so doing his voice is
actually kind of difficult because he
actually has some variation in his voice
and he pronounces his P's sort of his
B's so he's it Pepa right not not people
bepah like like Bieber and and also with
President Trump you can also you can
riff so earlier this week the outtakes
from the show by the way are phenomenal
I mean I really at some point should
start making outtakes available to
subscribers because they're so good so
earlier this week the president was
talking about flipping and for
legitimately 15 minutes after the show I
just did a president Trump impersonation
him talking about other things that I do
not like about flipping I do not like
one time I was on a trampoline and I was
jumping jumping better-better jumping
than anyone else the highest jumps the
best most spectacular jumps you have
ever seen and I tried to do a flip but I
failed and I landed on my hair ever
since I have been very much against
flipping oh so I once flipped a house
did not make a profit but created an
open-concept kitchen with formica
countertops in Atlantic City it was
great
also I like flips the Britta's with
chocolate on top of them they are quite
delicious flipping is some flips are
good some things are bad
Michael Colin is bad because he flipped
I don't like flipping I don't know I do
like flipper the dolphin
that was a good dolphin very smart
dolphin very very with it that dolphin
maybe the best often so some people say
some people say maybe the best dolphin
so it's the front president Trump lies
it in the batter
I think it's whenever I get to do my
impersonations it makes me happy and I
think it makes other people happy too
Jerry Brown is also a personal favorite
very underused Jerry Brown because he's
really not in the news all that much but
Jerry Brown the governor of California
is one thousand years old and every so
often he just said every every one of my
Jerry Brown impersonations ends the same
way I do
I'm here talking about the wildfires in
California and those fires very hot I
haven't had enough or they always end
with him sort and then he sort of just
falls over
ever every sort of Jerry Brown
impersonation ends with him falling over
so our might impersonations all that
great no but are they fun yeah I kind of
enjoyed them so thank you that okay time
for some things I like and then we'll do
some things that I hate so things that I
like there's a great book by Mona churn
it's called sex matters now the only
problem with this book is the same
problem I had with my second book porn
generation which is that when you put it
on your shelf people think are weird
because they say can the name of the
book is sex matters right I remember
when we came up with the title for porn
generation I thought to myself does
someone want to put that on their coffee
table the answer it turns out was no but
sex matters is actually a really good
book how modern feminism lost touch with
science love and common sense Moniz has
some really controversial stuff here and
she can get away with it because she has
in fact a woman with a career but she's
also a person who was you know very
high-powered in the in the 90s and early
2000s and she took some breaks from sort
of her life in public specifically in
order to take care of her kids she talks
about how feminism has corrupted views
of sex views of relationships has made
people unhappy and how to undercut some
basic scientific truths the book is
really good and really useful and Mona
is a really clear and compelling writer
you should go check it out sex matters
by mona Charen definitely well worth the
time okay time for some things that I
hate so the social media policing is
just astonishingly ridiculous at this
point so there's apparently a guy named
israel broussard he's in a Netflix
series called to all the boys I've loved
before I guess he's one of the stars of
that unoffending winning the room has
seen it but in any case he was he had to
officially apologize for his quote
inappropriate and insensitive words and
likes on social media so we're not just
policing people from what they say on
social media we are policing people for
retweeting or liking certain tweets what
were his great sins well he did tweet
out some stupid stuff about Japanese
folks right after there was an
earthquake in Japan he tweeted something
out about Japanese people eating dogs or
something silly like that but here is
the part from The Daily Beast that was
truly bad here's the part from The Daily
Beast that was truly truly awful okay
while those tweets are bad enough
Broussard's likes were apparently even
messier shared screenshots show that his
recent likes included Trump and Marco
Rubio tweets oh no not Marco Rubio that
radical
looking not see not Marco Rubio whoo-hoo
huh running for the hills israel
broussard my god that man is a covert
he's a covert white supremacist he liked
the tweets of Hispanic senator from
Florida no how could we possibly
also multiple gems from me oh no he
liked some of my tweets this means he's
a very bad person and just like Mark
Duplass who had to be shamed into
apologizing for ever having met me
now israel broussard has been forced to
apologize for having liked tweets by
Trump Marco Rubio the President of the
United States a senator from Florida and
me what was it what would my bad bad
tweets here's one of my bad bad tweets
this is the the one that is the worst
one that daily B's could find that he
liked okay ready the travel ban is not
Japanese internment immigration
enforcement is not Nazi Germany read an
effing book that's really bad you
shouldn'ta like that because it turns
out that the travel ban is Japanese
internment immigration enforcement is a
Nazi Germany how dare are israel
broussard by the way that's wheat just
just so we can note this okay that's
what was seconded by a bunch of folks on
the Left who still have the honesty to
recognize that Nazi Germany is not
actually us arresting people illegally
crossing our border by the way it worked
noting not a lot of folks attempting to
illegally cross into Nazi Germany that
was not actually the big problem
a lot of folks tell me to leave not a
lot of folks attempt to eat like you
know what honey we need to move to Nazi
Germany little sounds awesome that was
actually not their big problem as it
turns out and then I love this this a
Twitter user captioned their posts look
at this this is some of these are some
of israel broussard most recent likes
seriously israel broussard spikes are
the biggest pro-gun pro-trump pro effing
shapiro bro ben effing shapiro anti
muslims blacks and women mess and so
he's compelled to apologize this is the
world we live in now if you like a tweet
from me you'll be forced to apologize
Hollywood beware the scourge of
Hollywood lurks on your doorstep Here I
am so ridiculous okay meanwhile CNN
demonstrating once again it's non bias
its total objective journalism they are
now running a documentary it's like a
ten part documentary on Ruth Bader
Ginsberg the most important justice was
ever lived
what important decisions has she been
involved in the answer is not many she
really hasn't written many important
decisions at all virtually all important
decisions of the Supreme Court written
over the
last twenty years particularly on social
issues have been written by other
justices but she's very important
because she is a woman and a feminist
and oh my god so CNN is running I kid
you not a a documentary from CNN films
called RBG beyond notorious hey did they
ever run anything like it's about
Antonin Scalia or Clarence Thomas now of
course not
they only do it about Ruth Bader get but
they are objective they're totally
objective most liberal justice leftist
justice on the bench where the notorious
RBG I hate this kind of stuff so much
they kind of worship of judicial figures
like Antonin Scalia Great Justice
Clarence Thomas even better justice are
we supposed to like do we call him like
the notorious Clarence Thomas the
notorious Antonin Scalia the notorious
RBG but they say it with it's it's
supposed to be ironic because of course
she's a nerdy white lady a nerdy white
Jewish lady but here's a little bit of
their documentary don't worry this is
all objective journalism
she had the theory that right from early
on she had the theory that that
injustice is or do these special
privileges that women had hurt everybody
and it just put the women on a pedestal
but it hurt men also I mean what at what
a hero Ruth Bader Ginsburg is what at
what a heroine standing up for abortion
I'm just what what a heroine what it's
yeah don't worry CNN's objective you can
definitely definitely trust them so well
done CN n once more okay final thing
that I hate for this week so we have to
prefer Jake's beer in every way possible
and make it suck also so apparently out
magazine is now promoting a version of
Romeo and Juliet that takes place 50
years after society has exterminated
cisgender men so cisgender men will no
longer exist cisgender men are men who
identify as their actual sex in other
words like men right cisgender men are
just men so I'm confused as to how the
society exists 50 years after cisgender
men have been exterminated
I assume the baby-making rates have gone
down rather dramatically since cisgender
men it turns out are sort of necessary
and let's just put it this way if
cisgender men were completely eliminated
in Western civilization I think pretty
soon Western civilization would no
longer exist for both internal and
external reasons there be
people at the gates a lot of barbarians
at the gates who would be attempting to
destroy what was left of Western
civilization and also turns out you need
some cisgender men on that wall and you
need some cisgender men to make babies
and be fathers and take care of families
again none of this is to say that
transgender people can't perform
relevant and great functions in American
society but to pretend that cisgender
men are the enemy is ridiculous anyway
they're going to do this routine where
Romeo and Juliet it includes six female
and gender non-conforming actors as well
as a fully female and gender
non-conforming crew so I'm confused as
to why fully female is okay but not
fully male so males are very bad here is
what they're their pitch says as the
government still relies on martial law
to keep the factions in check two young
heirs unexpectedly fall in love one is
from the Montag's the militaristic war
mongers responsible for the purge of
societies men the other is the Capulets
controllers of information in the media
fighting to regain independence from a
sovereign state the genderqueer version
of the play the magazine says explores
mainstream feminism patriarchal
structures in a society struggling to
rebuild in their wake
sounds awesome sounds awesome forget
about the fact that Romeo and Juliet is
probably one of the most explicitly
gendered plays in Shakespeare it is
specifically built on the idea that
young teenage men are reckless and young
teenage girls are romantics it's a very
very gender specific play and this is
the good thing about good writing what
good writing is is writing of the
character you want to write a a
quote-unquote genderqueer character go
for it that's your problem but to hijack
the words of Shakespeare that are
specifically written for a man or for a
woman and then to pretend that those are
equally applicable to people who do not
identify as a man or identify as a woman
is really it's really amazing the same
people will say Scarlett Johansson
cannot play a transgender person well
now say that Shakespeare's words that
were written for a specific character
should be read by somebody who does not
resemble those characters in any ways
and is not trying to act as the
character but his acting as a completely
different character saying those words
it just doesn't make any sense on an
artistic level but I guess it's forward
thinking so who cares forward thinking
just means having nothing to do it the
original intent of the author so glad
we're doing that alright well we will be
back here on Monday try to survive over
the weekend it's been a long week we'll
be back here on Monday and we will break
it all down for you I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018